hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast tissue biomarker analysis
a practical approach for translational
research presented by dr. Grady Carlson
field application scientists
quantitative pathology solutions
PerkinElmer and dr. Linden Wyatt field
application scientists quantitative
pathology solutions PerkinElmer I'm
Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab birds and
sponsored by PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is
a global leader committed to innovating
for a healthier world their innovative
detection imaging informatics and
service capabilities combined with deep
market knowledge and expertise help
customers gain earlier and more accurate
insights to improve lives and the world
around us for more information about our
sponsor please visit PerkinElmer comm
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and I mean time
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window click
on the arrows at the top right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left
your screen for the complete biographies
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. Wyatt you may now begin your
presentation
all right great Thank You Alexis and
thanks everyone for attending this
webinar Grady and I are really excited
to share some information with you about
PerkinElmer approach to multiplex
immunofluorescence which we call
fanatics and just to be clear when we
refer to fin optics we're referring to
the suite of reagents imaging
instruments and image analysis software
that we use for multi spectral imaging
background I'm sure we're all aware of
the role of the immune system plays in
carcinogenesis whereby failures of the
innate and adaptive immune systems
result in the missed opportunity to
suppress tumorigenic cells leading to an
equilibrium state between normal tissue
and tumor tissue over time the loss of
antigenicity of the tumor tissue and the
resulting immune suppression leads to
tumor escape and outgrowth
role does the immune system plays in
carcinogenesis is extremely important
and using the immune system as a tool to
probe and treat cancer has represented a
paradigm shift in oncology cancer
treatment in particular has made
tremendous strides forward through
immunology where engagement of the
immune system as shown here in the case
of a polymer map has led to a very
significant increase in recurrence free
survival and it's important to remember
that when we're looking at this kind of
stuff these data are not just numbers
they represent meaningful differences
for real people but as
time passes we realize more and more how
complicated the immune system is and
traditionally we've been probed we've
been forced to probe multi-dimensional
systems like the one Steen on the left
with somewhat one-dimensional IHC
techniques like da being hematoxylin as
shown on the right
our experimental techniques like flow
cytometry might be great at telling us
about the existence of different cell
populations and even about their
relative sizes but they don't preserve
any of the spatial context of the tumor
micro-environment more and more we're
seeing how valuable those spatial data
are and that the story that those data
tell is sometimes quite different and
much more meaningful than the story that
we get from typical IHC techniques or
flow experiments
for the goal of the go
our Panoptix portfolio is to enable
researchers to image up to six
biomarkers simultaneously in one piece
of formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue as you can see in the image here
we've used our oval reagents to label
six distinct markers simultaneously in
one piece of human breast cancer tissue
after imaging using our vector polaris
instrument we use our inform software to
separate the signals from the seven
floors which includes the EPI
counterstain speed in the bottom right
in two separate channels so that we can
quantitatively evaluate the locations
and co localization of various
biomarkers
so looks like this first staining is
done using our opal reagents which
allows users to label six antigen
simultaneously while using whatever
primary antibody they've been and while
using whatever primary antibodies
they've been successful with in their
previous IHC or IAF experiments next
imaging is done on one of our three
multispectral imaging instruments this
instrument shown here is the vector
Polaris which is our fully automated
fully enclosed system that can hold 80
slides and does whole slide scanning but
we also offer some instruments built on
typical microscope platforms that offer
various levels of automation and flight
capacity finally our informed software
is used to unmix and spectrally separate
images and to do different image
analysis tasks like tissue segmentation
self segmentation phenotyping and data
analysis
this workflow allows users to produce
really meaningful and interesting
results in this study done by Bernie
Fox's group at the Providence Cancer
Center in Portland Oregon doctor for dr.
Fox's group set out to compare cell
populations in tumor and stromal tissue
samples from patients with HPV negative
oral squamous cell cancer at first
glance a comparison of cd8 positive cell
density on both the tumor and stromal
sides of the invasive margin correlates
the cumulative survival in patients
that's shown in the top left on the on
the top row of plots here but they only
they found that only the cd8 positive
cell density was a meaningful metric not
Fox p3 or PDL one which is somewhat
counterintuitive even more surprisingly
when the group compared ratios of 53
positive cells to cd8 positive cells and
tumor and stroma samples both ratios
failed as prognostic indicators of
cumulative survival
but next the group delved into the
spatial information provided to them
through the use of our multiplex
immunofluorescence tools and here they
found that the numbers of Fox p3
positive cells within 30 microns of cd8
positive cells in the tumor provided a
great prognostic indicator and this
metric makes sense because more Fox p3
positive cells near cd8 positive cells
would indicate greater levels of immune
suppression and in fact the numbers for
this metric did predict lower sorry
higher numbers for this metric did
predict did predict lower cumulative
survival
phox group was initially able to
stratify patients by human of survival
with about a 24 percentage point
difference between high survival and low
survival groups using what is
essentially a typical da B and
hematoxylin IHC stain
however developing after they developed
a cumulative suppression index based on
the spatial analysis of multiplex if'
data the group was able to stratify
patients with about a 70 percentage
point difference between the highest and
lowest survival groups this study is a
great example of the power of the
information that you can generate using
our phone optics approach to multiplex
immunofluorescence
and the thing is that we need to make
more progress before we can truly claim
the immunotherapies our precision
medicine we still have problems
answering questions like how do we
predict which patients should receive a
certain immunotherapy or can the same
checkpoint blockade test be used for
different therapies that target the same
checkpoint take the studies shown on the
right as an example this study looked at
patient response to katroo de and in the
study 59% of the patient population that
had high levels of PDL one expression
and looked like they would respond to
katroo de didn't respond to the
treatment this is indicative of the
distance that we still have to cover
it's also telling that one of the four
ft that only one of the four
fda-approved PDL one assays received a
companion diagnostic designation and
also fda approved a PDL one tests which
are based on mono flex assays
demonstrate some benefit in therapy
decisions their overall predictive
values are still poor our feeling is
that through phenomics we can provide
the valuable data that government
current experimental techniques can and
that we can improve immuno oncology to
the point where we can confidently call
it a precision medicine
now I want to go over our workflow in a
little more detail starting with
staining using our opal reagents
staining with opal floors is an
iterative process that involves labeling
and stripping steps and uses indirect
labeling and tear amide signal
amplification this approach allows
allows the user to target antigens of
interest with primary antibodies that
have already shown success and the
process of labeling and stripping means
that any primaries can be used without
having to worry about species cross
reactivity as you can see here an
antigen of interest in yellow has been
targeted by the primary antibody which
has then been targeted by a secondary
antibody conjugated to a horseradish
peroxidase polymer
next the tissue was incubated with terra
my conjugated opal floors the secondary
antibody HRP complex catalyzes the
covalent bonding of opal floors two
phenyl groups at the antigen during
floor four incubation in a stripping
step microwave or heat treatment removes
the comparatively weakly bound
antibodies leaving only the strongly
covalently bound opal floors
of primary incubation secondary
incubation floor four incubation and
stripping is repeated until all six
target antigens are labeled
allows us to routinely detect six target
antigens and counterstain with Daffy's
so that a seven color image can be
acquired by our imaging instruments each
labeling step is similar to da b
staining where the OPA floor four is
substituted for da B
additionally this same mechanism can be
used with a CDS RNA scope assay which
allows users to label RNA with
fluorophores this means that users can
visualize RNA and protein expression in
the same slide which is great for
answering questions about post
translational regulation among other
things
from here I'd like to turn it over to
Grady who is going to walk us through
the rest of the workflow and present a
couple of case studies
Thank You Lyndon I'm going to talk about
vector Polaris and our other
instrumentation for multispectral
imaging multispectral imaging is a key
component of our workflow because it's
what enables us to image all seven
colors in a single tissue section at the
same time
so what differentiates multispectral
imaging from conventional imaging well
with conventional imaging with a
red-green-blue camera or image we would
see just those colors red green or blue
but our eyes don't know the difference
between whether or not we're seeing a
color combination or if we're seeing
those colors individually
additionally when we use traditional CDC
CCD monochrome cameras we're relying on
narrow band filters to separate out our
channels and when we use our nail band
filters with more than four colors
we're very susceptible to bleed over so
what we do with multi spectral imaging
is we actually step through the visible
spectrum and 20 nanometer increments and
characterize the emissions of our floor
force and by doing that were then able
to specially unmix those floors using
our single sting controls
an example of what one of these spectral
libraries looks like it on the left hand
side where we have Daffy Opel 520
showing cd4 in green opal 540 showing C
20 in red opal 570 showing CDA and
yellow and opal 620 showing Fox p3 in
orange
additionally cd68 is shown by opal 650
and seek a show of my opal 690 now each
of these opal floors can be seen on the
left hand side and we can see that using
the liquid crystal tunable filter that
is used in our multi special imaging
platform we've captured both the shape
and intensity of these spectral
emissions and we've unmixed them to
separately see all seven different
colors
in addition to separating our different
fluorophores we're also able to remove
autofluorescence to increase the
accuracy of antigen quantification here
we've removed autofluorescence from a
sample of breast tissue in which we were
typing EGFR by removing autofluorescence
we increased our signal at the
background ratio from 0.7 to 1 all the
way to 18 to 1 vastly improving the
accuracy of antigen quantification
we have three instruments that are
capable of multispectral imaging we have
our mantra which is essentially a manual
microscope with the liquid crystal
tunable filter equipped camera which
allows for multispectral imaging in both
brakefield and fluorescence modalities
we have the vector three six slide which
does the whole slide image or six slides
at four X in ten X resolution and this
is also capable of doing bright field
and fluorescence imaging and the
multispectral imaging in regions of
interest and we have our vector Polaris
the vector Polaris is our highest group
with instrument equipped for whole slide
scanning in both Brayfield and
fluorescence and is also equipped for
multispectral imaging
work flow with Vectra is to take a whole
slide skin a whole slide scan is shown
here where we go in very much like a
traditional fluorescent scanner and take
an image of the entire tissue
next we choose regions for multi
spectral imaging so for example here I
could specify to take these three fields
of interest for multi spectral imaging
then dr. Polaris would go in and do the
multi spectral imaging with that liquid
crystal tunable filter select I can then
unmix those images in our inform
software
speaking of the inform software let's
move on to talk about the inform
analysis with our inform software
analysis suite which is a machine
learning platform
floo for our informant analysis software
is to first perform the spectral and
mixing using the library I mentioned
before
once the image is spectrally unmixed we
can then teach inform how to analyze an
image because remember it's a machine
learning software so by teaching inform
which regions of the tissue are tumor
and which regions are stroma I can
actually have inform analyzed my images
for me and segment tissue into tumor and
stroma
and then move on to segmenting cells
again through this machine learning
software teach inform how to recognize
these individual cells inside of the
tissue overlaid in green here
next I can click on these cells Intel
inform what types of cells they are by
phenotyping them when I do that inform
learns what cell types are represented
by which markers and can then phenotype
the cells when XY coordinates in each
image these XY coordinates will be very
important as we move on to
doing spacial investigations
each of the dots shown here represents a
single cell that has been phenotype by
inform and the different cell types are
differentiated by color
we can also score which is an intensity
based thresh holding
where we can actually score the
intensity of different markers on the
cells for further analysis
so an example
how we can use the spatial relationships
for analysis that are captured by the
finger typing of inform is shown here
where we've actually used a touching
cells algorithm that we have in our Finn
after sweet and what we're showing here
is cd8 t-cells in pink that are touching
tumor cells in cyan and so this is just
one example of the types of questions
you can ask of in terms of what cells
are touching and what's my infiltrate
density at in my tumor
to move on to another case day that uses
some of these spatial analyses I'm going
to refer to a study on pancreatic cancer
I'm done by Julie's Karstens in dr.
calories lab and in this paper they
looked at pancreatic cancer and they
actually used eight colors to to look at
their samples now this was an
interesting investigation because not
only did they use the multiflex but
having the multiplexing ability was very
important for them because there was a
very limited amount of tissue available
and what they did was they characterized
the t-cell infiltrate
inside of the tissue and they looked at
the percentage survival of patients that
had high and low t-cell infiltrate and
they found that patients were stratified
by percent survival between low and high
t-cell infiltrates in addition they
found the same for t-cell subpopulations
except for the T Reich population
next they looked at the spatial
relationships between these different T
cell subpopulations in the tumor cells
and they found that of all of the T cell
subpopulations only the cytotoxic T
cells stratified patient survival
indicating that there was something
important about these tenets toxic T
cells that were in close relationship
with the tumor cells within this 20
micron radius shown here again they were
able to perform these analyses because
inform allows you to get the XY
coordinates off of your image for each
cell that you phenotyped
they then looked at the decimal plastic
elements of the tissue because it was
postulated at one point in time that the
dismal plastic elements might actually
prevent T cells from targeting or
migrating to tumor cells but something
that was revealed in this investigation
was that rather than pushing T cells
away to stromal elements such as movie
multiple muscle antigen and collagen
actually drew the T cells in towards the
the tumor so rather than pushing T cells
away they didn't limit they being these
stromal elements didn't limit the
invasion of T cells toward toward the
tumor cell
this briefly I wanted to mention that
we're not only limited to investigating
immunotherapy for for cancer but also we
can use this technology to investigate
transplant research for example here I'm
showing a slide a study done in interim
Paris and here they were looking at NK
cell infiltrate on cardiac tissue and
what they found was that NK cells are
recruited in both cases of acute alert
cellular rejection and antibody mediated
rejection but that this localization was
different between the two modalities of
rejection and so this is a good example
of how this technology can be applied to
two other types of biologies other than
cancer and immunotherapy
so just to summarize briefly what we've
talked about today Synoptics reveals
spatial interactions between cells and
context of the micro environment and the
entire tissue which allows for analysis
of biological interactions on multiple
scales
ople multiplexing and Parkin Elmore's
multispectral imaging allows for
simultaneous detection of multiple
antigens in tissue and multi special
imaging and spectral and mixing removes
auto fluorescence which greatly improves
antigen detection of course ople
multiplexing allows you to continue to
use your chosen antibodies from unittest
chemistry in simultaneously eliminates
unwanted antibody antibody interaction
and thank you all very much for
attending and listening
take questions
Thank You dr. Carlson and dr. Wyatt for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left your screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started our first question
is how do you characterize and remove
autofluorescence
this is Lyndon thanks Alexis I'll take
care of the [ __ ] take care of this
question so the ability to for us to
remove autofluorescence is really one of
the things that I think our users find
so valuable and it's also something that
no other companies in the multiplex
imaging space can really do our approach
to autofluorescence removal is to look
closely at the auto fluorescent spectrum
and to unmix it from the spectra of the
other floors almost as if for um almost
as if the auto fluorescence is generated
by another floor for so to do this users
need to image an unstained tissue
section that corresponds to the tissue
type that they're studying in their
project when the user prepares to unmix
images and inform the user imports their
auto fluorescence image and gives the
software a sample of the auto
fluorescent spectrum and then the
software on mixes the signals of all the
fluorophores and auto fluorescent
simultaneously this is a nice solution
for the user because since
autofluorescence can vary widely between
tissue types all they need to do to get
really robust autofluorescence removal
is to image an unstained tissue sample
of the tissue type that they're studying
so this typically adds just one extra
slide to image per study
okay our next question is going to be
duck dr. Carlson let's go over to you
you mentioned that inform nice excuse me
imagine that inform use of machine
learning
how would you train the system for
tissue types and cells that it has not
encountered before so that's a good
question and typically when we encounter
the situation someone will have some
sort of immune cells in their tumor
tissue that is present in some images
and not others and so my recommendation
for that would be to train on your
positive control so if you stained in
tonsil and you have positive controls
these immune cells in topple tissue you
could train inform how to look for these
cells in your positive control so that
when you're the screening for them in
your cancer samples and you want to go
through and perform your analysis so you
can characterize those spatial
interactions then you'll have that
baseline of your positive control to
work off of but we do need an example of
that cell type so we can teach inform
what to look for
now dr. Wyatt with regards to the opal
staining workflow does the opal workflow
allows for different and optimized
incubation conditions for the primary
antibodies
Thanks up yes the short answer is yes
the opal staining workflow does allow
for different incubation conditions for
primaries typically the antibodies that
people use for their ihd assays are
translatable into our workflow and
primary dilution x' primary antibody
delusions are usually pretty similar to
what what's used for IHC
so let's let's continue on with our
questions how many biomarkers can be
measured overall
yes this is Grady so currently we're
detecting six antigens and seven colors
in tissue but as you may have heard some
of our user group meetings that's going
to be soon changing to nine colors so we
did detecting eight antigens and nine
colors and tissue
looks like we are getting we are getting
a couple more questions and so let's
continue here's our next one is there
any training possibility to use this
technique in our research
you
one this is Grady so the training
possibility meaning is there any way
that they can learn how to use this
course if that is the question then yes
we do have a training course that folks
can take with us called opal University
and they can come in to our site in
Boston and we'll take them through this
dating process and the image analysis
process
now dr. Wyatt what the unmixing of
spectra also count for on the overlap of
individual floor spectra and what does
it do to compensate for overlaps thanks
yeah our approach one of the big
advantages to our approach is that it
does account for the overlap of
different floors which is something that
you can't always do when you're using
you know using a multiplex imaging
approach or multi spectral imaging
approach that just uses narrow band
filters so basically the way that we
kind of compensate for that is by using
spectral reference slides which are
tissue slides that are stained with
single floor fours and then we build
what we call a spectral library from
these slides so we can kind of tell the
software what the fluorescence spectrum
of each slide of each floor sorry alone
looks like and that's kind of a brief
overview of how we do spectral mixing
we're going to give all of our audience
just a couple couple more minutes to
answer any questions but just as a
reminder if we do get any more questions
that we don't have time for today or any
questions during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
and so look as so if there are no more
questions we would like to think again
dr. Carlton and dr. Wyatt do you guys
have any final comments for our audience
I don't have anything thanks so much for
your attention this is really fun for us
thank you very much
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
just a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
the speaker via the content excuse me
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank laborat and our
sponsor PerkinElmer for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through April of
2019 leverage will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that emote your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye